with siding with three numbers now
can I remind you why three numbers boys
get used whether you're in simple
interests or you're in compound interest
you need one of the three pieces have a
look which one rich what's the fuss on
principle
second one is it isn't robust again
we've got the interest rate and then
you've got your number time series down
yeah okay by the way every time I say
this I'm going to try anyway I'm gonna
say number of time period don't fall
into the trap of saying number of years
because as you see in a minute these
isn't always what you're dealing with
and I want you to think consciously what
is the time period is this is it Matt
don't use of Shiva Q now to pass this
question I'm actually doing one more
session for you but once the punchline
the first question is what's the total
amount at the end of the sixties is that
correct I remember in the water
questions I tell about yes
so what we're going to do is let's just
start by quitting this time right the
compound interest photos with here's a
equals and I'm just going to write it
down so now I'm writing it as just as a
mechanism for myself so that I don't
have to remember and subdue the same
time which I often mess up when I did
shootings at the same time I just get
confused okay so now I can remember
first and substitute second and separate
this person so now I'm just going to fit
what I need into the right spots it's
little complicated so we've got them in
order in fact 6501 plus what would I be
to write for the range of integers
okay let's convert that zero point zero
seven and then the power is going to be
sleeps now one your calculator you've
got a button for square you've got by
the cube there is the step button for
raise the power of stick so what you've
got to go for is on my calculator which
is most of you
beside the square button just to the
right you've got this hot PR removed you
can fill it any power that you like
we're going to finish meeting okay so
once you do that okay so here's why I'm
getting do I have any agreements you
happy yeah okay so they're both too
complicated and remember this is not
just about flying out in the bills
though where what I've calculated I'm
going to describe if the amount which is
very important as I move to the next
pilot question if I'm remembering
correctly it asks what's the issue
okay now the simple interest formula it
gives you interest right off the bat but
the compound interest audience is not we
need tiny bit a leg work to get there
what am I going to do fantastic so I'm
going to say I interest that's why I'm
calculating right now it's equal to what
the total amount is after that six years
of pot and I'm going to choose to track
what I started with which was principal
is our mr. so this light here there's
not much complicated stuff in there but
it helps me know all I see you know what
interest actually represents it's the
difference how much has been created by
now I'll put some numbers in place
you having so much fun on the toilet so
just like before I've written down the
three essential numbers can you help me
recognize them again
first are not there any others it was
that principal second on a trip there
forever that means rest and then you've
got a two years which is so we would
normally designated em however even
though the compound interest formula the
forties formulas they only had three
numbers in them there's actually a
fourth number that's hiding there you
just have to know how to interpret it
coming in this ratio to try to be into
the question you see it is compounded
quarterly do you notice that yeah okay
what does that mean it actually changes
what happening so off on the side here
I'd like you to write down with me it's
kind of like a parallel set of
information I need to solve this
question properly they say compounded
quarterly so now even though it goes for
three years the number of years is
unimportant
it's the number of quarters the matter
now I've chosen this was a fairly easy
example how many quarters in a year
so how they call it in three years
eighteen so instead of writing two years
on the side here I'm gonna write eight
water there are eight quarters eight
times a quarter you sure that's up to
you so if I've got time shoes in
quarters well that means I need the
interest rate not forever
but per quarter as well so not only do I
have to translate this number I can
multiply that 1 by 4 what do i doing
this w don't get 3% every single corner
that'll be amazing what do you get
you get a quarter of that four times a
year that make sense if you have 3% over
the course of the entire year
then each quarter they'll give you a
quarter of that that makes it so I want
to work out what's a quarter of three
percent if I'm doing it right I'm pretty
sure it's 0.75 percent okay now that is
per quarter so one of those I've
translated this question out of the
number 0 or 4 into the numbers that
really matter the quarters will be more
of them so I multiplied by 4 the
interest rate you're getting less of it
each time so that's why I've divided by
4 so I devised I thought into this I
multiply by 4 to get to do okay so now
I'm going to write down my work a just
like before I'm going to write P and
side 1 plus R to the N well I'm going to
be careful to use the right rate and the
right number of time periods
okay principal out the front that's
still going to be and that man now the
rate again just like before I'm going to
convert it into a decimal but it's a bit
tricky right how am I have any
discipline to move this me to turn it to
a decimal
- right so it's currently 0.75 so I'm
going to move it two places so it will
be 0 0 75 or alternatively if you
finally get that a little bit confusing
you can just write 0.75 practices that
double do it but I prefer to look at it
all right what will work Tala be how
many quarters Hey and you're going to
get a figure out the air let me see if I
click you
9440 $8.23 agreement yes wonderful okay
can I just point out for you and if
you've got another color if you've got
another color I'd love you to add this
one this is really easy what you
mentioned is really easy to markup right
there are two major points where
specifically to do this thing here they
converted a decimal incorrectly
I am so for example a lot of people just
write 0.75 so say yeah I look like a
decimal to me but a difference in 5%
it's a hundred times smaller zero
certified so incorrect conversion is the
first thing okay the second thing is
connected to these two numbers remember
I said to you two years three percent
that's nice but I only users of it I
have to translate them into the right
tightening right so they forget the
translator
okay they leave it your knees they'll
just write down this instead now right
8900 the principle in principle and then
you'll write this zero point zero and
three squared
okay now I'll just quickly constitute
that for you I could tell you right now
it's going to be less than our heads are
it's on five nine hundred forty nine
thousand four hundred forty two dollars
so you're missing six dollars off the
end okay
cold tell you more frequently it earns
you more money which is why base these
days pretty much they're all best
torpatty everyday okay